yeah so my name is Tom augsburger I work
at anaconda and I want to thank them for
letting me come out here and then also
for letting me work on open source
projects for a living so I could work on
pandas and ask as my day job and today
we're talking about scalable machine
learning with SQL sled as an important
caveat is I tried I don't have any like
good general advice for scalable machine
learning we're gonna get really specific
in today's Kamel for better or worse so
fair warning there and with that in mind
I should ask who in the room is has ever
heard of dass before okay so that's good
and and who has actually used it at
least once
that's okay no bad okay I think yeah
given that I think we will spend a
couple minutes talking about desk itself
so you know we we have this kind of
problem where pythons a great language
for data analysis but if you're in the
last session you know you would have
seen that you can't you know pandas
numpy these to these tools kind of fall
down when the datasets start to get
larger than memory I think I can say
that one fan is that so they're they're
just not appropriate for larger than
memory datasets
okay and so with that in mind is we want
to that's like kind of the reason task
is around is they want to take these
existing tools and scale them out to
bigger problems okay so very very
briefly that is desk takes these
projects like numpy and pandas and works
with them to extend them to bigger data
sets so a single task array is made up
of many numpy arrays okay so when you're
actually you know doing computation on
the cluster we're still using numpy so
if you have a regular NP dot ones here
and you change that to a desk or a ones
you know you're still gonna have end up
with numpy raised only desk is going to
be calling MP dot ones a whole bunch of
times okay it's going to be partitioned
somehow along multiple dimensions okay
and we need to do a transpose
of this desk right it's gonna do a whole
bunch of numpy transposes and desk will
coordinate all that similar sort of
thing with pandas is a single desk data
frame is made up of mini panda state
data frames so you'd read in a directory
of CSVs or parque files or whatever and
that's going to be partitioned along the
index okay this is a basic idea the rest
of this doesn't really matter like these
these user interfaces that you'd use
like the first place you run into desk
is probably going to be with something
like - Garre or - data frame these are
the the data structures that you'll run
into they're all built on the same sort
of thing task scheduling doesn't really
matter the only other thing I want to
show from here some cool pictures give a
skip all these is is distribute
execution so desperate on a single
machine fine for like medium sized data
sets stuff that's bigger than maybe
maybe the memory of your laptop it'll
read in bits and pieces of the data as
needed so to do stuff out of core
scikit-learn and like extra boost they
already do really good single machine
parallelism so everything I'll be
showing here today will be about
distributed distributed machine learning
okay basically cuz you know the the
single machine is already handled pretty
well so with that in mind - this is the
network architecture there's a scheduler
there's some workers doesn't really
matter but - does deploy in a bunch of
places okay so I've got a cluster
running on Google cloud on their
kubernetes engine runs on HP you know
traditional HPC systems Hadoop and spark
clusters as well so if you have
questions about that I won't be talking
about it all but let me know afterwards
okay all right so I'll jump back to the
desk ml the scale machine learning one
actually before that any questions on
task itself before we get into the
machine learning part okay I do want
this you know be interactive discussion
and all that and I'll repeat the
question so people can hear it okay so
the way I like to think about this is
kind of along two axes here so you have
you know you're doing some machine
turning workflow type thing you might
run into scale along two axes so on the
first one the vertical axis here is the
model size so this is this is basically
when you become cpu-bound because you
have some large model typically you know
that could come from big ensemble models
so your single model is made up of a
whole bunch of smaller you know
component models so like a random forest
with a bunch of decision trees inside of
it or something like a big hyper
parameter optimization thing well
generate a whole bunch of mostly and
deployment tasks that can quickly get
you cpu-bound okay on the other side on
the other axis is we have RAM bound or
memory bound problems so those are the
cases where you can't really even load
the data set into memory much less pass
it through to a machine learning library
like scikit-learn okay so those are the
the two axes and kind of my ideal
audience member is somebody who is quite
happy you know inside this little box
they have a workflow that they like here
using a cycler next reboost numpy and
pandas but they're they're kind of
bumping up against one of these
constraints and looking for ways to work
around those right alright so yeah we'll
walk through that landscape here
starting off with CPU bound problems so
the other cases where the the data set
does fit in memory
okay so numpy and pandas are still fine
but it's getting to the point where
training and prediction is just taking
too long you know not just because
you're impatient you want things to go
quicker it's you know it does affect the
workflow of developing a model it's an
iterative process right so you're trying
things out so you say what features
matter maybe try some different
transformations all this you know takes
time and if it's taking you know a day
or whatever it's taking too long to
train a model you want to speed that up
somehow ok so a few solutions maybe you
don't need a complex model but you're
all good data scientists you surely
tried out a linear regression as a
baseline right you always do that first
before moving on to something more
complex so if you do actually need that
more complex model couple options you
can always usually buy a bigger machine
or rent one
you can rent some really big machines
these days so that could be an option
and and if it is an option then you
should probably go with that because the
other option you know distributed
computing is just fundamentally more
complicated than singing machine so you
save yourself a lot of headaches by
staying on a single machine for as long
as possible but if you do happen to have
a cluster lying around which some people
do then - can be an option so let's take
a look at that to see that so the first
first way you can do relatively easily
do distributed computation to put your
cluster to uses if you're using psycho
learn it internally is is this library
called job Lib so it's developed with
you know by the cyclone developers and
basically what it does is anytime in
scikit-learn where you have this in jobs
parameter that's controlling some
parallelism inside the model okay so you
say in jobs equals minus 1 that says use
all of my cores to do whatever you're
gonna do in parallel ok so in the case
of like a random forest
that'd be fitting you know all the trees
in the forest independently so there's
some big for loop and in scikit-learn it
does this big job load parallel for loop
over all those trees fits one and each
one independently so job live will do
that on a single machine using threads
or processes but if your single machine
isn't big enough for the problem that's
where where you can use staff so we've
worked with the job web developers we
implemented this parallel back-end this
desk parallel back-end and so you know
in terms of you know lines of code
change you need an extra import you need
to make sure that the fit call happens
inside this parallel back-end and then
you know any anything that touches job
Lib inside this model which you don't
have to worry about that'll actually be
handed off to desk and desk will make
sure it happens on the cluster any
questions on that we'll take a look at
that now hopefully alright so I've got a
cluster running here 100 workers 1 Corps
each and I've connected it to it here so
this is just some gas stuff
super important I'll talk about what all
this is in just a second
and then I'm going to load in the data
so this is coming from the New York City
Taxi Cab data set got you know
information on like each one of these is
a taxicab ride in New York City these
the subsets from 2014 as things like the
number of passengers the fare amounts
locations things like that and our task
here is to predict whether or not
whether or not the tip amount was
positive okay that's our classification
task it doesn't really matter we don't I
don't really care about performance I'm
just you know doing a scalable machine
learning here so it's an example so in
this case we're gonna fit a little
pipeline here so standard scaler for the
first part and then a random forest
classifier and two things to note here
first of all we have 100 individual
trees so this is where the parallelism
comes in and we're gonna say in jobs
equals minus 1 and so when I run this
this is gonna be running on the single
machine that I'm connected to here I
think as 8 cores so this is just regular
old scikit-learn running on a single
machine takes about 10 seconds or so not
using the cluster yet okay so I finished
in 12 seconds all right
now let's say yeah we were really
digging this model but we think we could
go deeper so we're gonna try a thousand
trees now just because so in this case
that's the only thing we're changing is
a hundred to a thousand still have n
jobs equals minus 1 the rest of its all
the same we could just take this
pipeline and fit it on our small
in-memory data set it would finish in
roughly like 120 seconds or so ten times
as long since there are 10 times as many
trees but if we want to tap in on the
cluster we'll just have this little
parallel back end here and then some
stuffs gonna start happening over here
so each one of this is a number of tasks
processing per worker so that's that's
happening over there and then a few
other things to know is this is the task
stream plot so each one of these green
ish things is a single fitting a single
tree and then vertically I guess
go across horizontally here each this is
this line horizontally is a single-core
on my cluster so this one this core was
busy fitting this one tree and those
idle for a bit and those fitting another
tree and then idle for a bit so going
across that's the activity of a single
core and so I have a hundred of those
lines vertically here yeah so just
finished up here yeah a few things note
that's a relatively easy change and it
got some speed up it didn't get a
perfect speed up though okay
so there's a couple reasons for that
first of all distributive computing is
you know fundamentally harder than
single machine so you have to do things
like serialize the model which takes
time you have to send it over the
network which takes time and then when
it gets the worker you have to
deserialize it which takes you know a
couple seconds so if you notice you know
when I started that there was a couple
of seconds like four or five seconds
there before stuff started happening on
the cluster that's like overhead that
you don't avoid or that you don't have
to worry about with the single machine
so we're not getting a linear speed-up
there's also some inefficiencies here
like there's no reason this clusters
these workers should have been idle here
that's something that we should fix with
the job live developers but it's you
know some batching thing that that's you
know and then inefficiency there that
you probably wouldn't have on a single
machine okay any questions on that
yeah is there any sense to having more
than one core per worker for sure
yes um it depends a bit on the
computation pattern but yeah that'd be
just fine and desk would be using those
workers appropriately there yeah in the
back what's the plotting sorry oh this
is the desk lab extension yeah it's a
Jupiter lab extension I think is what's
called that lets you show that
unfortunately oh wait progress is the
one I want this one wasn't active I
don't know why
right from reconnecting I want that one
to take up the whole side here sorry one
sec okay gotta lay it out oh no
lay it out just right
we must be painful for you all sorry
okay uh still doesn't look like it's do
anything yeah we'll see okay so that's
that's the first example there and then
it were there any other questions sorry
is messing with my [ __ ] set up yeah yeah
so the question was is there any more
any benefit to picking an efficient
serialization structure and yes
absolutely so in desk it you know in the
weeds desk will do stuff efficiently for
you and you if you have a custom object
you can register it you can register
with that so that your custom
serialization is used
yeah yeah so the question was if I have
a dead friend do I to worry about
pulling out the numpy rays you don't
have to worry about it because that's
does exactly that for you okay okay so
for the next little example here another
cpu-bound problem so we're still gonna
be working with this small in-memory
data set fits on all the workers we're
gonna be taking a look at hyper
parameter search that's what this gif is
an animation of is the - scheduler
walking through all the tasks in a hyper
parameter search you could easily use
the same job Lib parallel back-end trick
because a second learns grid search CV
and randomized search TV both taken and
jobs so you could definitely reuse the
same thing we're gonna actually use the
drop-in replacement from desk ml I'll
talk about that while it's running
actually oh I forgot to scale up my
cluster oh no this could take a little
longer um that's okay
maybe I play on that so as these new
workers come in they'll just get
assigned tasks and it'll be fine
I just have to wait for some more VMs
from Google to come up not a big deal
okay so we're gonna import desk ml the
model selection and we're gonna use that
for the grid search CV rather than cycle
urns and we're gonna go ahead and define
our pipeline so same pipeline as before
except just for time
for the logistic regression rather than
a random forest it's a little quicker
also all the parallelism will be at the
outer level Mouse that's a bit easier to
understand I think it's and we've got
this you know big ish nah I mean not
huge hyper parameter space we're
searching over okay so the API is the
same is you've got an estimator our
little pipeline here we've got a
parameter grid and then some number of
CV splits can you actually see it read
this on the back okay yeah so in this
case we have 600 independence or mostly
independent you'll see models that we
fit and then choose the best one amongst
those how many workers do we have a
hundred and four still now they'll come
online all right so we'll go ahead and
fit that again single you know small
data set fits in memory right now so
we're just looking at CPU bound problems
on the progress tab this is what's what
was not showing up earlier the reason we
used the the desk ml models grid search
CV is we get a bit nicer names here so
if you saw the one from scikit-learn I
forget what it was but it's something
like a fit tree batch or something not
nice like that basically by the time job
load gets done with it - loses the name
of what the actual thing is so this
looks a bit nicer so we have nicer names
here like standard scaler fit transform
you can see that's the first stage of
the pipeline um you can also maybe see
it's a bit small as we only have three
of those right and you only have one per
CV split of the data in the scikit-learn
implementation right now you would
actually have to call that fit transform
600 times it's a little inefficient you
do have the 600 different hyper
parameters for logistic regression
though so or the 200 times three for the
CV split so that's a nice little
optimization there that might matter I
don't know if you saw it just went away
I'm gonna bring it up here you saw our
new workers this is blocked by the
kernel right now but you saw the new
workers come in I think
I'm gonna go to the taskstream it's like
you know these were our initial set of
workers here and then I thought where'd
it go did I click something new workers
came in here and new workers came in
here so that you can see that desk is
dynamic and as new as workers show up at
they'll get tasks it's almost like I
planned that I didn't I promise it's
pretty cool though and that finished in
a minute and 40 seconds and and at that
point it's a regular regular grid search
object you have things like best score
you can take the CV results and you know
see how things do over the hyper
parameter space it's just a regular CV
search object at that point any
questions on that one
yeah what about when workers fail we
might see that actually because I was
having failing workers for some reason
and I didn't figure it out but it
depends if a worker fails because like
I'm running these ons preemptable spot
instances so maybe Google comes along
and says okay this VM is going away in
that case it's like the the like desk
itself will handle that failure and the
tasks that we're on that machine will
get assigned to other tasks if if like a
worker fails because your code like
raises an air that air will come back to
you if it's a seg fault because of your
code I'm not actually sure what happens
the work will definitely go away desk
has a check and like if a single tasks
like is going it'll reschedule on the
next machine the seg fault again
reschedule on the next machine sake
fault again I think three times so it
depends a bit on the exact nature of the
failure
yeah so if you have each worker can have
multiple threads and that's fine but if
the worker fails all of the tasks that
are there gone yeah all those will be
rescheduled
okay any other yeah yeah yeah so the
question was what effects like how dense
this task stream is and you know in
general it's a good intuition that white
space here is bad because that's where
the cluster is idle so the the there's
there's a few things typically that
happens when the overhead of the desk
scheduler is larger than the the time it
takes an individual task to run the
overheads is a it's some like one I
forget there's like a per task overhead
for the scheduler so you want tasks that
are at least that long so you know in
the second two or so range at least that
or it's like the 100 milliseconds or so
range if you're below that then the
overhead of the scheduler is gonna
dominate the efficiency you get from
parallelizing so that's the biggest
thing is how long each task takes which
is a function of the data how complex
the function is things like that the
size of the data sorry okay let's jump
back to this okay so that's CPU gun
problems putting into that and then
moving on to memory bound problems so
these are cases where your data sets
actually getting larger than memory in
these cases numpy and pandas start to
become the bottleneck you can't even
really load the data into into memory
before passing it off to the side can't
learn or whatever 2xg boost and so you
have to figure something out there may
or may be not so the first solution here
is maybe a plot a learning curve and you
decide hey it turns out I don't actually
need all my data my estimators doing
fine on a subset so yeah we'll see that
an example of that solution one the
first real solution here
maybe you can again buy a bigger machine
I create what AWS is recent announcement
was it was like 2 terabytes of RAM or
something crazy like that so you can buy
buy or rent pretty big machines and so
obviously the this fits in RAM bar I
have here this is relative to the size
of the machine and so you can extend
this out pretty far ok but at some point
maybe you know you have you do really
have big data at that point you're gonna
have to figure out something so my
suggestion just a suggestion is rather
than using numpy and pandas you would
use a desk data frame or desk array to
load in the data and it'll use numpy and
pandas behind the scenes but you load in
the large to the memory data sets and
then use different algorithms so you
can't pass like a larger than memory
desk array to a regular scikit-learn
k-means ok because it'll convert it to
an umpire array and bloat in the machine
the memory on your single machine ok
you do need algorithms that know how to
work with these data structures or know
how to work like block wise or
incrementally so we'll see examples of
that but like I said the first one you
might want to look here is plotting a
learning curve so this is taken from
this I can't learn Docs if you want you
can do it in parallel with that but the
basic idea is you have some some data
sets and you fit it or some data set in
some model and given that model you know
look at the performance over the number
of samples the number of training
examples so in this case you know it
depends on like the business question is
you know is this additional improvement
from 800 to 1400 examples at points you
know one or two percentage points is
that relevant to your use case that
depends maybe it is maybe it isn't but
you know certainly by fourteen hundred
or so samples this SVM is not improving
really and just you know throwing more
data that's not really going to improve
your model okay
so always check that before you go to
distribute in the shame learning for
sure because if you don't have to deal
with that headache then you shut it
okay real briefly I think we have a bit
of time yeah so at least on my last job
is quite common we're getting
labels for training data is really
expensive and so we would very rarely
have larger than many memory training
data sets just because we didn't have
the labels but we did like our
population of interest was larger than
memory that full data set so we would
end up doing a whole bunch of stuff
where you know you Fitz you train on a
smaller you know an in-memory data set
and then have to predict for a larger
than memory data set there's a few ways
you can use desks to help you with that
so you know the idea is you can use this
parallel post fit I don't like the name
if I yeah it machine learning people
would call this like parallel inference
or something but I'm an economist so I
do not think that prediction is
inference so I'll fit you know you wrap
up your model it's a meta estimator so
it's an estimator that takes an
estimator you wrap it up the fit is
identical so we really do just pass this
this fit XY through to the to the real
model the history diem boosting dot fit
fit is identical the only thing that
changes this prediction so prediction or
predict prob a or scoring things like
that that can be done really easily in
parallel okay and so you know rather
than you know passing in a big you know
daiquiri or whatever which would you
know crash your machine for the single
the regular model with this wrapped
version we're able to do that prediction
on the cluster that's scoring on the
classroom yeah that's basic idea there
anyway just an aside okay so if you do
actually have large learned memory
datasets and you want to do some
training then in that case you can use
kami I'm sorry - can we implement some
algorithms some estimators from scratch
okay we'll take a look at a couple of
those look at k-means first shut down
that and I'll connect to my cluster here
so again getting a hundred workers we're
gonna look at at these distributed
algorithms just random dataset sorry
this this - Kamel about datasets makes a
big hundred thousand hundred million by
100
arrey on the on the cluster and actually
so - grace lacy so this did nothing and
this client dot persist is what actually
made it start doing stuff on the cluster
this is happening yesterday - I'm gonna
refresh that bytes uh memory use worker
hain put that here okay so you can see
we've got a hundred gigs allocated on
the cluster now alright and now we'll
we'll do with k-means so yeah this I
should say like so implementing k-means
from scratch it's more work implementing
new estimators there's quite a bit more
work than like reusing what sardian
scikit-learn or whatever but there are
like you you just can't pass a desk
array a large then memory desk grade to
the scikit-learn k-means you have to you
have to do something here it turns out
so we made we made some different
algorithmic choices here so it turns out
for k-means the only thing that's
somewhat hard to paralyze and distribute
is the initialization so scikit-learn
uses k-means plus plus that's hard to do
in parallel
apparently so we we implemented k-means
parallel which is the same algorithm
used by SPARC ml and yeah that's the way
to choose the initial set of clusters
and then you do things like the regular
you know for every point find the
distance the closest center and then for
all points closest to that centers you
know find the new average and do that
some number of times I capped it at five
here just because otherwise is it takes
a while to converge for this data set
but it'll finish up in a minute here
maybe we had a worker here I'm honestly
not sure what this what happened here
we'll see once once it finishes if we
have ninety nine workers here oh eight
and nine workers we had a lot of
failures that's strange not sure why
that would be but you can see the the
scheduler was resilient to it so that's
good I guess and then at this point you
have like inertia whatever that means
for this data set okay I want to ask for
a few more workers let's go
5120 okay oh no that's not good
zero workers sorry one sec try wreak
restarting everything mm-hmm
any questions on k-means while our
workers are coming back hopefully yeah
yeah yeah yeah so the question was you
know why do I do that parallel parallel
post fit fit XY rather than doing
something like you know for X Y in
streaming data set sorry about the typo
you know then do seal off that predict X
Y good question so the main that
parallel post fit specifically works
fine for works fine for out of core as
well and so the main thing is like how
do you how do you make this so either to
get the streaming data set thing you
would do something like you know you
you'd be writing those generators
yourself and so you'd have to be you
know four or file in glob glob data set
you know start out CSV so you know DF
equal PDI read CSV and then all that
other stuff or you can you know use do
that and then do this if that makes
sense you know if XY equal extract it
and all that so you can do that
basically you can you know it's a bit
more work to adjust that code or you
could use tasks to do DV out read CSV
star dot CSV and then you know it's a
little easier to migrate that like -
we'll handle that that kind of out of
core
streaming and chunks of the data as
needed for you so that's it's it's a
preferencing but for something like
batch prediction it's it's
embarrassingly parallel
it's like quite easy to do or you know
relatively easy to do in parallel on
your own if you want yeah I think I have
a cluster again that's good ok
we're not there yet so and then for the
last little demo here we've got hyper
band so this is an example of kind of
that top right section of the graph
where you're you have a CPU bound
problem like a grid search hyper
parameter search and you have a larger
the memory data set okay so one option
then is to use hyper band it was
implemented last year I think by Scott
Siebert and asked ml it's a relatively
new algorithm every Oh a year it's from
but relatively new a similar API though
is you have some classifier notably a
implements partial fit I'll talk about
why in a second and some parameter grid
that's fixed ahead of time and the basic
idea is you know you have some fixed
computational budget that you want to
allocate efficiently across all of the
models okay so the way hyper band works
is well let's let's generate some more
data so I'll want some circles here and
not really going to talk about des laid
basically I'm gonna take this data set
and scale it up a whole bunch this is
10,000 points I'm gonna scale it up to a
bunch I forget how many so that we have
you know 20 gigs on the cluster
you could go bigger but just for time
scaling it up with - blade it's desolate
it's a nice little helper to take like
numpy code and make it work with desk
anyway doesn't really matter we've got
some data on the cluster we specify our
classifier here we've got the parameter
grid here and we'll go ahead and kick
this off so yeah it's the same basic
idea if you've got your estimator and
your parameter grid a few hyper
parameters that kind of controls how
hyper brand submits training examples
basically so the the core ideas make
sense I think is you want to give some
some training examples to all the models
and then based on how they're doing
starts giving more training examples to
higher performing models and if a model
is not doing well then you basically
stop training in okay that's that's the
basic idea behind hyper band and we're
so nicely with desk
- dynamic task scheduling because we can
say if you look at this partial fit
that's the that's like the the main one
here you'll see that we have like 34
active right now that'll fill up and
eventually that denominator there will
change as we submit additional tasks
here so we're saying okay based on what
I've seen so far these are these models
are doing relatively well I'm gonna give
them some more examples or maybe like
this patience is saying you know this
this model hasn't improved even though
it's a high-performing model hasn't
improved in the last few iterations so
I'm just gonna stop training it even
though it's a high-performing model
that's the basic idea behind hyper band
it's pretty neat it fits nicely with
desk this will finish yeah just finished
up in a minute and you know we have the
at that point a regular object best
params best estimator CV results that
you can inspect and then the the main
new thing here is the history like
there's things like brackets and you
know over time like how did this model
do as it got more and more training
examples okay let's make idea wrapping
up so there's a bunch of stuff we didn't
really get to just like useful stuff
like train test split you should
probably be doing that there's some
utilities for doing that on that state
of frames and desk graze pre-processing
is relatively easy to do as well much
easier to do like a standard scaler than
a distributed gradient boosted tree or
something like that so pre-processing
there's a bunch of those desk a
cheetah's is a way to all the stuff I
showed with like scikit-learn it's not
specific to cycler and it works with
anything that implements the cycle earn
API so there's a desk actually boost
that does that when your model is
decomposition other other stuff we
didn't get to alright so just recapping
I said my ideal user attendee here is
you know a person who's in here in this
box
they like their workflow but they want
to extend it out to you know something
that's either CPU bound or memory bound
or both and there are some tools and
desk and all for that if you want to
learn more you can go to the docs MLS
org the main website for desk is that
desktop org also at examples desk org we
have a whole bunch of examples
bunch of machine learning ones as well
so yeah thanks yeah so I think five
minutes for questions yeah yeah yeah yep
yeah so the question was my all my
examples on a cluster can you also do
gasper similar stuff if you have a large
single machine yes you could and maybe
that would make sense for like if you
own like Reid and data and parallel from
a bunch of CSV use but then once you get
to like psyche learns single machine
parallelism is really good anyway
same with X you booze yeah so there's no
reason really for deaf Kunal to get in
the way there unless you're doing
something like the parallel post fit
where it's nice to be able to just like
keep your similar switch your import
statement from pandas to desk and then
do out of course stuff if you're if
you're doing out of course stuff some
stuff works well out of core I don't
know I'm not a huge spark user so and
I'm biased obviously since I met pandas
dev so no koalas for me and and the -
dev no it's it's good that it's goodbye
there are multiple tools one so if
you're if you are good at Doc's org we
have a nice comparison with spark here
it's probably on the spark yeah
comparison to spark there's a nice page
it's slash spark here so I would
recommend going through this it goes
through a whole bunch of stuff on this
on
not so much in the ml side of things but
there's a good summary here and I think
it's mostly fair it was written by us
but mostly fair basically if you have a
JVM you know then go ahead and probably
you spark write like if you've invested
in that or you know have data breaks do
it for you that's a perfectly fine
solution if you want to stick in Python
and you know if you like pandas and
numpy desk will reuse those as part of
its execution so like the runtimes not
changing
maybe that's important maybe not I think
there was a question here
No okay in the back there so which the
yeah yeah right right now so it sits on
kubernetes is the one that I was showing
in Google's kubernetes it's good as you
might expect it's getting better the
others are getting better so I think
yeah I haven't had experience with
deploying on AWS or Asher but they are
getting better the others are so Google
right now but it'll level out I'm sure
okay cool thanks Sarah